the world is becoming more and more an
urban place today there's 50% of the
world's population living in urban areas
and the next 30 years will add two and a
half billion people to that so by 2050
our expectation is that 70% of the
world's population will be living in
urban areas and I think the challenge
for all of us is to use this
urbanization as an opportunity to
address some of the real challenges that
the world faces economic challenges
social challenges environmental
challenges because they will exist in
some ways they have the potential to
expand if we don't get ahead of them I
think historically we have assumed that
we can leave this all these challenges
to the government to solve these
problems or the nonprofit community to
solve the problems and the business
doesn't need to get involved and I think
that's just no longer the case I think
business has to step up has to play a
much more active role not to replace the
government not to replace the nonprofit
sector but to bring its talents and its
expertise and its resources to be part
of the solution I mean the reality now
is government is able to do a lot less
they don't have the resources in many
ways they don't have the collaboration
and what's interesting right now is
you're seeing in cities and urban areas
not just all these people we talked
about but you're actually seeing the
kind of collaboration between the public
and the private sector the nonprofit
community in a way that's addressing
these challenges that you don't always
see at the federal level and I think the
private sector has a genuine
responsibility to step up and to use in
whatever case they may have their unique
set of capabilities and the resources
and their expertise to try to address
some of these challenges we can't thrive
if the communities where we operate
don't thrive if the communities are
failing it's not good for business and I
think that's the mindset that more the
private sector needs to needs to get
into that this is not something that can
simply be a little slideshow or just
contribute to some charities and that
that absolves you have any more
responsibility we all have a vested
interest in the success of our
communities in the success of our cities
and we've got to step up
and make sure that we're doing what we
can to help them grow and help them
thrive and prosper